عندما تعود يا حبيبي لمدة ساعة ، ثم سأذهب
الآن أتحدث إلى الناس مثل
المتقدمون للاختبار مثل كل مرة في أوقات صغيرة
سأفكر في الأمر لاحقًا ، آسف
سيكون دائمًا هو الشخص الذي تراه في المستقبل
أنا مجنون ولكني أحضر وساعد السيدة خميس
انظر إذا كنت سأذهب معك لأنني سأكون هنا في الساعة 20
مرحبًا يا رجل ، أهدر ركلة جزاء لشراء علب
تذكر أن تقود لإنقاذ سوبر ستار الخاص بك الآن أنظر
[موسيقى]
هذا هو فو مينه عندما آتي إلى هنا ، الصورة مرتفعة
ولكن أيضًا احفظ Happy Hour of English
ذهب السيد هونغ عندما كان أشقائي وأخواتي
خرجت فيلا لتلمح لي أنها كانت جميلة جدًا
أحبك من أجل قلب هاريبوتر
مدرس عائلتي ريو ثم أطلس
أنا أحبك ، هيا ، أنا قروي لأن
الناس لأنهم يطلبون أي سلع ، يأكلونها
مراجعة ثم prets Big Super لأن ما سيكون هنا
لأنني بعد ذلك أريد شراء أحذية لك
لم افكر في الامر حتى الان هل تريدين البكاء؟
ما الذي تكره النساء هنا مرة أخرى
عدت إلى الجبال وعدت إلى عائلة
في عائلة يوان ، أنت تقول حبنا
حدث لون غير مسمى في آسف
أخت أخت
نعم نعم